in our 24-hour town we have seen
terrible deadly crashes involving
drinking and driving Metro Police wanted
to stop they are targeting repeat
offenders 8 news now reporter Ryan
Matthey joining us live from Spring
Valley Parkway and Rainbow Boulevard
with just how they plan to do that Ryan
thanks Kirsten we've seen it time and
time again drunk drivers on Valley roads
and highways taking the lives of
Benedict bystanders and that's from the
general public all the way up to some
more high profile cases we're here
currently at a memorial for a woman and
her dog they were both killed by a
former the former Raiders player Henry
rugs he's accused of driving drunk and
speeding Metro Police now seeing
progress in their efforts to avoid
scenes like this ever again
a scene all too common in Las Vegas and
now Metro Police making sure repeat
offenders don't get behind the wheel
intoxicated again we knew a resting
wasn't going to get this problem solved
Mike Thiel lead intervention officer for
the Department's Traffic Division helps
run the DUI Intervention Program formed
after he says Las Vegas DUIs began
climbing during the pandemic we're
trying to reduce that rabbiticism we're
trying to say Hey you have that first
DUI you're now at that second the third
conviction is a felony and you're also
more likely to become a fatal or kill
somebody on our roads Police Department
officers go door to door of those
convicted of a second DUI with a social
worker they attempt to understand why
the DUI and how any more can be
prevented we have that person right
there with us giving them the services
out in the field versus just an officer
saying here's this information hopefully
you follow up heaven forbid something
happens to them or to you what then but
the programs on a volunteer basis for
offenders so how successful can it
really be about 40 people have been
contacted thus far roughly 70 percent
continue on with the program but to the
parents of repeat offenders like Michael
Martinez it may just mean the difference
between life and death my son if he
feels that he needs help
go for it and I'll push him for it and I
tell them go do it because I can only
help you so much
now this program actually began a full
year ago they've since brought on that
social worker in July now they also add
that nearly 200 DUI arrests have been
made in their jurisdiction alone in just
this year
reporting live in Spring Valley Ryan
Matthey 8 News Now
information from the FBI and U.S Census
Bureau show that Las Vegas has the
highest number of drunk drivers per
population size that includes tourists
Metro Police reports nearly 40 DUI
related deaths just this year